extrait de la campagne officielle de 74
votre première présidentielle en tant
que citoyen avec à la télévision un
candidat en pull-over rouge
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis tôt
rené dumont chez candidat écolo qui
prend un peu de son temps de l'antenne
pour mémoire ce verre d'eau pile poil
regardez nous sommes monde 2022 on en
parle il a eu raison mais avant que tout
le monde est mais on n'entendait pas il
ya 50 ans non non non pas du tout
pourquoi moi je sais que j'ai repris
cette bataille de l'eau parce que je
pense que c'est le prochain ça bien là
ça va être la grosse question pouvez
vous passer tous au dos donc je vais pas
vous faire mes arguments sur le sujet
mais à l'époque non n'entendez pas la
gauche était dominée par le
productivisme l'idéologie qui allait
avec si vous voulez on allait développer
les forces productives et on allait
développer tellement bien qu'ils
auraient pour tout le monde et donc tout
irait bien et tout irait mieux et on
était tous là dedans et on n'écoutait
pas et quand françois mitterrand par
exemple fait un éditorial dans le
journal du ps les poches moi s'appelait
l'unité alors il avait fait un truc que
l'oiseau qui s'étouffe dans l'air le
poisson qui se noie dans la rivière mais
d'éclater de rire les gens autour de moi
dit mais qu'est ce qu'ils racontent
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc les
oiseaux qui s'asphyxie dans l'herbe et
puis quoi encore non il y avait zéro
tolérance zéro écoute et quand il ya eu
le
le club de rome alors quand il ya eu il
ya eu un club qui s'est fait et en
réaction des intellectuels comme gb et
autres ont fait l'an zéro bon il
proposait de réduire justement le niveau
2 delà du productivisme il faut voir ce
qu'on disait à leur sujet coup la gueule
en grèce et des suppôts du capitalisme
ils veulent augmenter le chômage et
faire peur aux travailleurs enfin le
discours était complètement stéréotypé
bloqué paralysé et il a fallu que je me
trouve moi confronté à l'absurdité de ce
qu'on racontait que je me rende compte
que au fond les l'écologie politique
présentait la question du collectivisme
sous l'angle qui m'intéressait c'est à
dire les biens communs de l'humanité
comme une seule espèce animale bon et
que tout d'un coup je fasse le lien
entre ça et mon fondamental qui est la
philosophie humaniste et révolutionnaire
89 droits de l'homme pour que je
comprenne que tout ça se tenait et que
c'est ce qu'on racontait qui tenait pas
avec bon cette vision absolument c'est
du mauvais prométhéa c'est un prométhée
exalté parce que moi tout réglé par en
produisant produisant et en prélevant un
karl marx on l'avait lu que comme ça
pourtant marx est le premier à dire le
capitalisme épuise l'homme et la nature
mais ça nous intéressait pas à l'époque
voulait pas voir ça
[Musique]